so it's a great honor and pleasure to be
here today in honor of the inauguration
twenty-third president of Yale
University those of you who came
thinking that with this was a public
lecture may not have realized that this
is actually a comprehension quiz for
those of you who are alumni of the
directed Studies program so I'm looking
for identifications from the audience of
the five figures you see before you
seeing no volunteers these are the five
figures on to whom I will project the
five secrets to ancient and modern
flourishing that I want to talk about
today they are Socrates the ancient
Greek philosopher his student Plato
Plato's student Aristotle and then
moving a bit forward in history the
Roman philosopher Cicero and Epictetus
and what I want to try to articulate
today is why it is that the ideas of
these figures and the intellectual
tradition of which they are
representatives are ideas that would
have been studied if you were a student
at Plato's Academy in ancient Greece or
if you were a student in ancient Rome or
a student studying at one of the
original universities such as Paris in
the Middle Ages or what you would have
studied as a Yale student in the 1890s
or as a student at Yale in the 1940s
when students looked like this or the
1950s when they looked very different
like this or in the 1960s when they
looked very different like this and good
to know that change finally came
extraordinary Yale prom committee in
1974 this is so old its new again my
barista looks like that or this is my
own graduating class a time during which
even when we were dancing we were
struggling with the ideas of these
authors your students read them in the
night
90s and in the 2000s and they continued
to read them in courses that we teach
here today and what I want to try to
share with you is a common idea that I
think underlies not only the work of
these five authors but in fact most of
the world's wisdom traditions so though
the discussion that I'll be presenting
to you today draws almost exclusively on
the ancient Greek and Roman tradition on
the one hand and condemn per arey work
in psychology particularly work done in
America and England on the other the
ideas that are given voice to by this
tradition are ideas that are present in
every wisdom tradition that I know of
they're certainly present in the wisdom
traditions of what we call the East that
is in the wisdom traditions of China and
Japan and India and Korea and they're
certainly present in the wisdom
traditions of the Africa and the Native
American traditions so the fundamental
idea that I think lies at the heart of
all great wisdom traditions is that what
we might metaphorically call the human
soul the human mind the human spirit
human psychology exhibits a certain sort
of internal complexity in particular the
soul has both parts that we would call
reflective or rational or directly
accessible to conscious reflection and
it has parts that we might characterize
as non reflective as non rational in a
strict sense as not directly accessible
to conscious reflection and linguistic
articulation and flourishing tends to
occur when the parts of the soul are
appropriately aligned
that is when the relations between what
we might think of as the rational or
reflective parts of the soul and between
the non rational and non reflective
parts of the soul are somehow in a
harmonious state in a state that
whichever part of the soul is better
suited to be dealing with the situation
at hand finds itself in the position to
be controlling what it is that the mouth
says what it is that the hands do this
however exactly because the picture is
correct requires that the understanding
of this insight be one that is encoded
not merely in the rational part of the
soul that is it's not simply enough to
recognize with the reflective part of
the soul that the soul has parts and
that it's important for them to be
inappropriate relations with one another
exactly because of the fact that so much
of what we do and so much of how we
respond is the result of the
non-rational parts of the soul the
insight needs to be encoded both by the
reflective and by the non reflective
parts now the ancient Greek
philosophical tradition has language to
articulate these ideas it has a notion
of the kind of flourishing that I've
been describing a flourishing that
results from the appropriate harmonious
relation between the rational and non
rational or reflective and non
reflective parts of the soul and that
term is eudaimonia where diamond means
spirit we might translate that as
spiritual well-being and it also has a
term for being such that one holds a
proper reflective and non reflective
understanding of the relations between
these parts and that term is phronesis
sometimes translated as practical wisdom
so what I want to try to do in the next
45 minutes or so is to give you a sense
of five aspects of this world view the
world view according to which phronesis
and appropriate understanding of the
relation between the parts of the soul
can lead to your dude I know Nia
a kind of spiritual well-being so those
five aspects can be summed up in fairly
short bullet points though spelling them
out in detail is the project of a
lifetime
and those five aspects are these the
insight that will take from Socrates
concerns the importance of developing
appropriate self-knowledge which will
turn out to involve a rather ironic or
perplexing thing namely the recognition
that self-knowledge is inevitably
limited the second insight will draw
from Socrates student Plato the focus on
the importance of developing an
appropriate harmonious relation among
the parts but the question of how that
practically can be carried out is one
that will turn to the works of Aristotle
to understand looking at the value and
importance of habit in allowing us to
cultivate this kind of furnaces will
then look very briefly at the role that
social interaction can play in making
that possible drawing on some insights
from Cicero who himself is drawing on
some insights from Aristotle who himself
is drawing on some insights from Plato
who is actually just channeling Socrates
so it really is just one guy in our
story and then we'll close with some
insights from epictetus about
delineating the appropriate realms for
attempted control so let's begin with
our first character this is Socrates the
night before his death about
to drink the hemlock which he has been
sentenced to drink by the citizens of
Athens for having corrupted the youth
and here he is surrounded by his
students at the moment of his death
and Socrates student Plato goes on to
tell the story of the days leading up to
Socrates death in a famous dialogue
called the apology and in that dialogue
there occurs the following interchange
between a student of Plato's a Tsar a
student of Socrates and the great Oracle
at Delphi and the interchange goes as
follows
Kyra fawn asks the Oracle which is
supposed to give you the voice of the
gods
Kyra Fong says to the Oracle who is the
wisest of all men and the Oracle
responds by saying no one is wiser than
socrates Chiron brings this report back
to Socrates and in the apology Plato
goes on to tell us what it is that
Socrates says in response and Socrates
responds as follows when I heard this
that is when I heard that the Oracle
said no one is wiser than me I said to
myself what can the Oracle mean when it
says that no one is wiser than I am for
I know that I have no wisdom small or
great and he continues giving us some
insight into how it was that he managed
not to be the most popular man in his
city I went to one who had the
reputation of wisdom when I began to
talk with him I could not help thinking
that he was not really wise although he
was thought was by many and wiser still
by himself
Socrates provides a corrective by giving
his own opinion to the gentleman and
then the discussion concludes with
Socrates saying this so I left him
saying to myself as I went away well
although I do not
suppose that either of us knows anything
really beautiful and good I am better
off than he is for he knows nothing and
thinks that he knows where as I neither
know nor think that I know this insight
that self-knowledge requires a
recognition of the limits of rational
reflection in providing access to
motivation turns out to be one of the
central themes of contemporary work in
psychology so Socrates idea that one
source of wisdom is knowing what one
doesn't know and that this includes our
motivations and the source of many of
our attitudes that self-knowledge
requires humility knowing that one does
not fully know oneself can be seen as
the origin of a research program in
psychology sometimes known as
situationism which explores the ways in
which our responses to our environment
are often do not merely two facts about
ourselves but also two features of the
environment around us of which we may
not be consciously aware so in a famous
study which is one of the original
studies in this research tradition
psychologists looked at the difference
between people who were in one of two
different situations either the person
was sitting comfortably on a bench
minding their own business or the person
was walking across a high suspension
bridge that was above a large Canyon and
what the psychologists did is they had
somebody approach the individual and ask
them a number of questions and then
offer their phone number as a potential
opportunity for following up
if the individual had any questions so
in both cases the researcher came and
approached the individual and what the
psychologists were wondering was whether
individuals who had been approached
while they were sitting on the bench
would be more or less likely to phone up
the other the researcher then
individuals who had been standing on the
bridge when the approach happened and
here's what the results looked like when
the people had been given the phone
number when they were sitting on the
bench only about 30% of them gave a call
back when they were standing on the high
bridge when they'd been approached more
than twice as many did now what could
explain that difference in results what
are some of the feelings that go through
your body when you're standing on a high
bridge your heart beats fast your breath
is a little light your pulse feels
profound to you and what are the some of
the things that happen when you are
finding yourself attracted to a person
who has just approached you you know
your heart beats fast your breath is a
little short your pulse is something of
which you become highly aware that is
arousal that is due to one feature of a
situation being on a high bridge turns
out to be something that we can miss
read as having been due to a different
feature of the situation namely the
presence of an individual towards whom
we assume on the basis of our bodies
report we feel ourselves to be attracted
and over the decades since this study
was conducted we get repeated research
reinforcing this idea which in some
sense is just the idea that you're
cranky when your shoes are wet right or
that you're happy when the weather looks
like this but reinforcing this I
in a way that brings out that we are
often unaware of what it is that's
leading to our response and one of the
bodies of research that has been
generated as a result of thinking about
the way in which our responses may be
due to something other than this has
been conducted in the laboratory of our
own Yale colleague John barge and the
studies look like this you bring
somebody into the lab with the thought
that what they're going to be asked to
do in the context of the laboratory is
to evaluate a resume on the basis of
certain criteria how qualified is the
person how likely is the person to be an
effective receptionist in an office
where that requires a certain degree of
friendliness how capable do you think
the person will be of performing
activity a or B or C and the way they
run these studies is that right before
you come into the lab you undergo either
one kind of experience or another so you
might in the elevator have been handed
either a warm cup of coffee or a cold
cup of coffee and it turns out that
depending on whether you've handled a
warm cup of coffee or a cold cup of
coffee first your tendency to evaluate
the resume that you've been given as
belonging to a person with the warmth
necessary to make them an effective
receptionist will vary or you might be
given the resumes to read either on a
heavy clipboard or a light clipboard and
judge the candidate to have a degree of
gravitas that is higher if you've read
the resume when holding a heavy
clipboard than when holding a light one
and perhaps most disturbingly this is
research done previously to the work
done by Barton Williams you will
typically if a resume bears the name
that is of something
unmarked racially in contrast to a name
that is racially marked had a tendency
to evaluate the exact same resume as
indicating higher qualifications if the
name that appears at its top is an
unmarked name like Thomas then if it is
a racially marked name like Tyrone and
following in this research paradigm
Corrine Masri Kuzon inject a video and
Jo Handelsman and a number of other Yale
faculty recently did a very very similar
study on women in the sciences that
involved sending around resumes to
scientists throughout the country the
resumes everybody received only one
resume and at the top of it appeared
either a name that would typically be
read as a male name like John or a name
that would be typically read as a female
name like Jane and the results were as
follows individuals who had been given
the resume that had the male name viewed
the candidate as significantly more
competent significantly more hireable
and significantly more worthy of intense
mentoring than those who had received
the resume associated with the female
name and these results also for on the
opening salary that would be given to
the individual moreover all student
differences were significant regardless
of whether the evaluator in question was
himself a male or herself a female so
the effects of evaluation of the resume
were being driven not merely by what you
might have thought they were being
driven by the items that were listed on
the resume showing a moderately
qualified person for the job but also by
features of the environment of which the
evaluator was presumably unaware a
related study in this tradition looks at
what conditions are ones that promote a
kind of pro-social behavior so suppose
you have a coffee system at your office
that runs on an honor system where
you're supposed to put money into a
little pot every time you take a cup of
coffee and suppose above that
coffeemaker you put either a pair of
eyes or a photograph of flowers all the
weeks where what you have or the pairs
are simply the flowers as you can see
donations to the coffee club are not
particularly high that's awfully close
to zero but on weeks where you have the
eyes particularly these ones donations
are very high so in response to this the
philosophy department which runs things
on an honor system put up the following
sign this is a quote from Conte
two things fill the mind with ever new
and increasing wonder in all the starry
sky above me and the moral law within me
my colleagues were under the impression
that the reason this worked was because
of this quote but in fact our donations
weren't up because of mr. consul eyes
above our coffee maker so to conclude
the first insight Socrates says in that
discussion about the Oracles report that
he is better off than others not because
he has knowledge of the world but
because he has knowledge of his own
ignorance and it turns out that that
insight is a central one to contemporary
research in psychology in many cases we
are unaware of the sources of our
emotions of our choices of our
preferences and of our pursuit of goals
self-knowledge that is includes
knowledge of our ignorance but how could
we be structured such that this is true
of
this turns out to be a question of
central concern to Socrates student
Plato depicted here on the left
Plato recognizes something that is a
theme of all literary traditions namely
that there's a very common experience of
internal strife he tells the story
famously of Leontes who is walking back
to the city of Athens and sees along the
wall of the city some dead bodies which
he is intrigued by in the way that you
might be intrigued by a traffic crash or
by that column on the left hand side of
the CNN web page which has all of those
well you know sort of stories that seem
kind of exciting and intriguing but of
course you're not going to click on them
except you do that's what happened to
lay artists for a time he struggled with
himself and covered his face but finally
overpowered by appetite he pushed his
eyes wide open as you do when you click
on that story about well I'll leave it
to your imagination rush towards the
corpses saying look for yourselves he's
speaking to his eyes you evil wretches
take your fill of this beautiful sight
and on the basis of stories like this
one experiences like this one
introspection about his own tendency to
feel this way
Plato presents in his works two
different metaphors about the structure
of the human soul of which perhaps the
more compelling is this idea that the
human soul is composed of a charioteer
which is what Plato calls reason and two
horses one cooperative horse which he
calls spirit and one rather ornery horse
which he calls appetite and he says let
us like in this human soul to the
collection of this charioteer
and these two horses so the three parts
of the soul says Plato a reason spirit
and appetite and conflict among the
parts of the souls often leads to a kind
of feeling of internal conflict but our
direct access to these parts of the soul
as our discussion of Socrates has
already revealed to us is rather limited
we tend not to have direct access to our
horses and we sometimes even lack access
to our charioteer now this idea that the
soul has parts gets picked up again and
again we see it in the early 20th
century in Fords picture of the human
soul we see it in works like Daniel
Kahneman's Thinking Fast and Slow which
is in some ways an exploration of the
ancient idea of the multi-part soul we
see applications of it in Yale
University presses book nudge which is
an exploration of the ways in which
speaking to the horses or in the
Buddhist metaphor the elephants can
allow us to act in the ways that we are
reflectively committed to and we see it
in the work of our incoming university
president Peter salivate who's focused
on what Plato would call the spirited
part of the soul as central to human
behavior and motivation underlies the
project of the emotional intelligence
research to which he has been so central
so this idea that the soul has parts is
one that I have been exploring in my own
work for about the last decade and I
have found it helpful in so doing to try
to introduce some language to describe
the phenomenon that Plato is describing
in the story of Leontes where one part
of the soul is pulling one way
and the other parts of the soul are
pulling in another so if we were to
travel to the Grand Canyon which I
understand thanks to the taxpayers of
the state of Arizona has now reopened we
could if we wished pay a visit to this
horse shaped horseshoe shaped walkway
which extends over the Colorado River
and which has as its floor a transparent
glass surface there's a similar building
on Wacker Boulevard in Chicago which has
a glass floor now if I were to take you
there and we were to stand upon that
horseshoe shaped surface presumably no
matter how much you were trembling you
would believe that we were totally safe
if you didn't believe that we were
totally safe
it would make absolutely no sense for
you to remain there even for a moment
but nonetheless you would presumably be
trembling and shaking and that's because
though you believe that you're safe you
have what I would call an a leaf that
says - I'm really high up this is
absolutely terrifying I have to get off
this surface I suppose we want to see a
film I understand he had a second job
later on and one of the characters on
the screen pulls out a gun and shoots
and you duck presumably it's not because
you believe that film technology has
become so advanced that nowadays bullets
really come off the screen your belief
is that this is just a film but you're a
leaf is that you need to watch out so
you duck and speaking of watches is
there anybody here who does what I do
which is to indicate 10 o'clock on your
watch by means of this configuration of
hands that is to set your watch five
minutes fast and those of us who set our
watch five minutes fast know that we
have set our watch five minutes fast
when I look at my watch and it looks
like this my belief
it's ten o'clock that's what my watch
looks like when it's ten o'clock but
that's not what my horses think my
horses look and they think it's 10:05 I
better get to where I'm going how many
of you have ever had the experience of
watching a repeat projection of a sports
event whose outcome you know and found
yourself in the course of watching that
repeat of the sports event yelling
something to the individuals on the team
presumably when you are watching this
episode it's not that you believe that
if you yell don't run your words will go
through the screen back in time to the
individual who's about to get thrown out
at second base but rather what you are a
leaving that causes you to yell don't
run suppose you are trying to increase
your temporal dimensions by decreasing
your spatial ones you might find
yourself in a circumstance where though
you believe this to be undesirable
you're a Leafs are pulling in another
direction and likewise if I bring you to
my Halloween party where I am serving
this which has exactly the same
ingredients as this those are tootsie
rolls we were out of pans but I found
this at the store it's totally pristine
it is this not a spatula I the science
had been shifted around in the grocery
store if I try to serve you this
presumably you will believe me you came
to my lecture there were four other
lectures you should have gone to write
if you're not going to believe what I'm
saying in
this one but although you believe that
this is in fact made of the same
ingredients says that you're a Leafs
pull you in another direction suppose I
invite you to sign this document I
hereby declare that my soul belongs only
to you O Satan October 12th 2013 and
because I've done my online human
subjects training I put this at the
bottom the legal contract it's simply a
prop in a psychology experiment
presumably your reluctance to sign the
contract is not due to the fact that
Satan's favorite thought would be brush
script or like of course Satan would put
this on the bottom of the contract I
mean how else would he fool you into
thinking that he had gotten it past
human subjects right you resist this the
sign this contract has nothing to do
with you beliefs it has everything to do
with your aliefs and if I take you to
Monica Bondi Chinese incredible bathroom
installation this is a public restroom
that she installed on the streets of
Milan you will see when you walk into
the facilities that it is totally opaque
that you are at no risk at all of being
observed by the world but here's what it
looks like on the inside a leaf may
interfere with release
but this shouldn't surprise us right why
would we expect that beings whose
information processing systems are the
result of an incredible internal
complexity where different parts came
online evolutionarily speaking at
different times where there's a degree
of redundancy with regard to the kinds
of sources that we have for information
where there's a very limited part of us
which is it appears directly accessible
to conscious access why would we expect
that the soul would be any different
than Plato's picture and in fact every
wisdom traditions picture describes it
to be in some sense this is the picture
of the Leontes story but it's important
to recognize that although in the
various Alief stories that I told the
smartypants part of the brain was
getting things right and the dummy pants
part of the brain was getting things
wrong there is research that suggests to
the contrary that in certain sorts of
situations particularly ones with
respect to which the dummy pants parts
of the brains are well suited
ecologically that they will give us more
accurate reports than our smartypants
front part of the brain so if you stand
people in front of a hill and ask them
to estimate how steep it is particularly
in circumstances where they're tired or
carrying a heavy weight their verbal
reports will tend to overestimate the
steepness of the hill whereas their
haptic report a report that involves
putting your arm at the angle that you
estimate the hill to be will get the
answer correct or if you present people
with the famous muller-lyer illusion
your smartypants visuals
system thinks that this line segment is
longer than this one but if you reach
for them your dummy pants haptic system
your hands is much more accurate so I'm
going to quickly skip these two slides
because I've been going slower than I
meant to and move to a discussion of the
costs of strife before closing out the
discussion of Plato here so what happens
when the parts of your soul are in
conflict and you're trying to keep the
charioteer in charge what happens when
the reflective part of your soul wants
to do something and the non reflective
part of your soul keeps pulling you in a
different direction
so a large body of research explores
this question in the context of
interracial interactions in a society
structured by a legacy of black slavery
that would be this society and the
question that this body of research asks
is whether the encoding of implicit
racial attitudes attitudes that I would
call a Leafs effects our behavior in
certain ways even if our reflective
commitments are to behave in totally non
racist ways so for example there's a
large body of literature about whether
if you're shown a cellphone or a tool in
the hand of a person of African descent
you are more likely to perceive that
cellphone or tool as a weapon that is as
a gun this is research prompted by the
incident with amadou diallo young man
who was shot by police after having
pulled a wallet from his pocket so one
body of research looks at the ways in
which there's a tendency to recognize or
to attribute weapon holding
to an individual on the basis of their
race I already talked to you about the
resume study this is a study that just
involves simple interracial interaction
and the study which was conducted by
Jennifer Richardson uh in 2003 at
Dartmouth with Dartmouth students goes
as follows you bring students into your
lab and they interact either with a
research assistant who is of European
descent or they interact with a research
assistant who is of African descent and
all the students who are brought in to
participate in the study are themselves
students of European descent
so the interactions between the student
and the research assistant are always
completely Pleasant nobody has trouble
controlling their responses in the
situation but here's what which esand
does next she has the individual engage
in what's called the Stroop task the
Stroop task is one in which what you're
asked to do is to name the color in
which the word is printed sushi red
green blue yellow red green etc it's
pretty hard it's a good way to test
whether somebody knows a language right
if this were in Russian we can see
whether or not though you said you
weren't you're actually a speaker of
Russian but you can use the question of
the degree to which you are slowed down
in performing a script ask as an
indication of roughly how tired your
charioteer is how much work your
charioteer has recently been using and
how exhausted it is by the process of
having pulled on the reins and it turns
out that students who had just
interacted with a research assistant of
European descent were much faster at
doing the Stroop task then individuals
who had just interacted with the
researcher of African descent that is
their charioteer was tired and their
charioteer was tired because it had
spent a bunch of time pushing down
associations and in fact the effect
described here
Kove Aries with the degree to which the
person's implicit attitudes as measured
by a test developed here at Yale by
mahzarin banaji the implicit association
task the degree to which their implicit
attitudes and code typical racial
associations of our society so
conclusion from the Plato section and
then I will move quickly to Aristotle
the soul as Plato says is like the union
of a team of wounded horses in their
charioteer responses come from different
parts of the soul or as the picture of
the brain showed of the brain sometimes
they're in harmony sometimes they're in
tension and when they are in tension it
can be costly it employs a certain
amount of energy to keep the horses from
doing what you don't want them to do so
what strategies could there be for
keeping your horses in line that don't
involve direct involvement of the
charioteer this is the question whose
answer will turn to Aristotle for so
Aristotle writes and this is my favorite
quotation so much so that I've got it
four times in the next section of the
talks so if you want to zone out miss
this slide and I'll give it to you three
times again there's some rights people
become builders by building and harp
players by playing the harp so - he says
did we become just by doing just act
temperate by doing temperate acts
breathe by doing brave acts states of
character says Aristotle arise out of
like activities if therefore makes no
small difference whether we form habits
of one kind or another from our very
youth rather it makes all the difference
so here's a t-shirt which they wear at
MIT which students at MIT think is funny
and students at Yale think it's funny
that students at MIT think it's funny so
why is that shirt either first or second
order funny the shirts either first or
second order funny because it plays off
a distinction in the notion of law which
turns out to underlie Aristotle's in
site so we can distinguish as
philosophers and others do between laws
that express us ways things should be
sometimes called normative laws laws
like look both ways before you cross the
street or don't eat food in the library
or speed limit 65 miles an hour
so we can have normative laws on the one
hand and descriptive laws on the other
descriptive laws are things that tell
you how things are like if a car hits
you you will die or crime is called
cause book decay or speed limit 186,000
miles per second another MIT t-shirt so
the difference between these kinds of
laws is that the first kind of law
normative laws express things that you
ought to do or should do you should look
both ways you should not eat food in the
library you should go fewer than 65
miles an hour whereas descriptive laws
Express facts Aristotle's insight is
that patterns of behavior that are
initially under conscious control that
are initially the result of a commitment
to shoulds become automatic as a result
of our having done them habits are tools
for turning normative commitments views
about the way things ought to be inside
you into descriptive truths ways that
you as a matter of fact behave one of
the things yale is trying to re-instill
in all of us is this habit before I
cross the street I habitually look both
ways and we can see the extent to which
we've encoded this if you grew up in
England and come to America or if you
live in America and go to England it's
incredibly hard to cross the street and
it's incredibly hard to cross the street
in fact you've automated crossing
routine and when I get to England I find
myself looking a hundred times back and
forth because it isn't evident to me
even though I know reflectively they
drive on the left what it is that I
should be doing if you hand me an item I
habitually without reflection say thank
you this is what parenting is about it's
about instilling these sorts of habits
in kids but of course there's no rule
that says the only things that can be
encoded through habit are things that we
reflectively endorse habits are also
tools for turning counter normative
commitments odd knots into descriptive
ones when I turn like on my computer I
have virtually choose your sin mine's
number four but they're nice aren't they
all right so this idea that you see in
Aristotle's ethics is picked up in this
recent bestseller by Yale graduate
Charles Duhigg and it is I think the
central idea and one the work of one of
our other electors this weekend Alan
Kazdin who gave or perhaps right now is
given his lecture on bullying
so when Aristotle is speaking about
moral education in the context of the
ethics he says this if arguments were
sufficient by themselves to make people
decent that is if simply talking to the
charioteer we're enough to make the
horses behave then arguments would
rightly command much praise but it's
impossible says Aristotle to alter by
argument what has long been absorbed as
the result of habits how do we make
changes we become just by doing just
actions temperate by doing temperate
ones brave by doing brave actions and
this is exactly what you find in the
literature of cognitive behavioral
therapy and the applications of that
literature in scientifically informed
books about parenting what you find in
them is an articulation of this
Aristotelian insight instead of thinking
about what you don't want somebody to do
instead of talking to their charioteer
start try
their horses think in terms of the
behavior that you do want to promote and
then provide opportunities for
reinforced practice of the desired
behavior the best way to build up a
behavior is that way and I think that
we've heard that before
because we learn a craft by producing
the same product we must put as when we
build it we've become builders by
building harpists by playing the harp
just by doing just actions temperate by
doing temperate actions that is the
insight that underlies scientifically
informed parenting guides or self-help
books like the doing habit book is this
fundamental Aristotelian insight that
habits are tools for turning normative
commitments into descriptive truths
moreover there is a kind of circularity
to this reinforced practice the more you
engage in a behavior the more natural it
becomes the more natural it becomes the
easier it is to engage in it without
effort so in conclusion habits are tools
for turning us into iza's we learn a
craft by producing what we must produce
when we've learned it harpists by
playing the harp builders by building
just by just I told you I would give it
to four times temperate by doing
temperate ones in shorthand if you want
to become something as if that's what
you already were and if you do that
often enough it will be what you become
but habits are hard to change habits are
particularly hard to change in isolation
and habits are particularly hard to
change without a community of support to
enable that and in the final two
episodes of the talk and I'll wrap up in
less than 10 minutes I promise I want to
talk a little bit about the role of
social interaction in the context of
friendship and
a little bit about the classification of
activities into ones over which we do
and don't have direct control so let's
turn it now to the work of Cicero again
the articulation of this view that I'm
giving you comes from the work of Cicero
but the ideas that are here are actually
central to Aristotle's own discussions
of friendship
Cicero right how can it be worth living
without the mutual goodwill of a friend
is not prosperity robbed of its value if
you have no one to share your joy
friendship says Cicero improves
happiness abates misery it doubles our
joy and divides our grief somehow in the
face of another it becomes possible to
gain a kind of perspective on one's own
actions in the face of a true friend
writes Cicero we gain as it were a
second self so this idea that the
support of community is crucial to our
well-being it's something that is given
central place in the work of
distinguished Yale alumnus Jonathan
hight he writes in his book the
happiness hypothesis if you want to
predict and and this claim is based on a
reading of the research if you want what
it how happy someone is or how long
they'll live you should find out about
their social relationships having a
strong social relationships strengthens
the immune system it extends life even
more than quitting smoking though may
add you should do that too it speeds
recovery from surgery it reduces the
risk of depression and anxiety disorders
that is being embedded within a
community of others with whom one has
healthy reciprocal relations of
affirmation and support turns out to be
unsurprisingly for evolved social beings
like ourselves as you might have learned
Loree Santos's talked yesterday turns
out to be central to our thriving but it
also turns out to be a way that we can
experience moments that are challenging
as less challenging so I told you
earlier that studies seem to have shown
that if you estimate how high a hill is
when you for example you're carrying a
backpack or you're really tired
you'll verbally report a hill that's
like 10 degrees as being on must be 25
30 40 degrees unless unless you're
standing next to a friend and if you're
standing next to a friend the effect of
the backpacking causing you to estimate
the hill as being so steep gets
mitigated and you're more likely to see
yourself as easily able to perform the
activity participants accompanied by a
friend estimated the hill to be less
steep than those who were alone if they
thought of a friend you don't even need
to be with them you just need to
remember them perceive or at least
report perception of the health as less
steep this idea that friendship and
support of community is valuable is a
central idea in the Buddhist notion of
right association which explores the
question of what preconditions need to
be in place to allow you to make the
sorts of changes to which you are
reflectively committed so before setting
out on the path to enlightenment the
Buddhist tradition encourages you to
surround yourself by others who share
the ideals towards which you hope to
bring your own horses or in the case of
the Buddhist version of the metaphor
your own elephants
and the tradition rights of the
following when a wild elephant is to be
tamed that is when you have a way of
behaving that you reflectively disavow
that you want to begin to change here's
what you can do you can yoke yourself to
one who has already begun the process of
change by connecting yourself directly
in interactions in a way that makes it
evident to you that somebody else is
already behaving in the way that you
wish to by contact it becomes apparent
not just to your reason but also to the
non-rational parts of your soul that the
condition towards which you're striving
is not wholly incompatible with being an
elephant that what is expected of with
you
heralds a condition that does not
totally contradict your nature and
continues the teaching the constant
immediate and contagious example of a
yoke fellow can teach as nothing else
can and to play out the metaphor as with
the elephant so with the life of the
Spirit now we already saw the ways in
which feeling one's self to be observed
by another can change behavior there's a
large body of research that shows that
simply putting a mirror in a room so
that you feel observed taping a pair of
eyes onto your computer so that you feel
looked at can cause you to engage in
behavior that you are reflectively
committed to behaving in but that your
horses were somehow reluctant with
regard to that is that friendship not
only is a way of magnifying joy and
reduced
grief that is the positive social
contact magnifies emotional pleasure and
tempers emotional pain but that in the
face of a true friend one can see a
second self in the presence of others we
can develop new patterns of perception
and response of course the question of
where we should devote our energies in
undertaking these processes of change is
a crucial one and regarding that I will
turn in the final section to the very
first explicit self-help book ever
written one might think of Aristotle's
Nicomachean ethics as a self-help book
but epictetus is handbook was literally
meant as a self-help book and it was a
book that was read by virtually every
person educated in the Western tradition
for many many centuries this one happens
to be John Adams personal copy let's see
his name in the upper right hand corner
Epictetus writes in the famous opening
pages of his book 2,000 years ago some
things are up to us and some things are
not up to us
our opinions are up to us and our
impulses our desires our versions in
short whatever is our own doing but our
bodies are not up to us nor our
possessions nor public reputations and
if you make the mistake of mis
categorizing says Epictetus you are
doomed if you suppose the things that
are not up to you are up to you you will
face constant frustration because you
will be trying to control what you
cannot and as a result you will limit
you will be disturbed and you will find
fault with both gods and men but if you
restrict your efforts to an appropriate
domain you will be fine if you think
that is
that only what is yours is yours and
that what is not your own is not your
own then in some ways you are immune to
the world's vicissitudes no one can ever
coerce you no one can hinder you no one
you will blame no one you will accuse no
one you will do not a single thing
unwilling it now some of you may find
yourself reminded of something by this
thought some things are up to us some
things are not up to us when I ask my
students whether it reminds them of
something about 22 percent can identify
what it reminds them off and a bunch of
them think that maybe they've heard it
before and about a quarter of the class
wonders why I was asking that question
what it reminds you of presumably is the
Lord's Prayer composed apparently here
at Yale in 1912 by Reinhold Niebuhr god
grant me the serenity to accept the
things I cannot change courage to change
the things I can and wisdom to know the
difference which you can find decorated
with morning glories or puppy that's
from the dog parade this morning or this
sweet angel or a little praying girl or
you can put it on your ashtray because
you read the John Haight and you think
all I need are some friends or you can
get it tattooed on your arm or your
elbow or the side of your chest the
ideas that underlie the fundamental epic
Aten insight are central to the programs
to which it's been given rise in
particular to 12-step programs and their
cousins because it turns out that it's
true that some things are up to us and
some things are not up to us and that
although we cannot directly control many
things in the world we can directly or
amendment due to our first four lessons
in directly but indirectly in
predictable ways control many things in
ourselves
but in order to determine which ones we
are capable of controlling and which
ones we are not we require a certain
kind of self knowledge so that's the
full circle that I want to come and I
want to close with a little epilogue
about an individual who found these
lessons to be exceptionally valuable in
an exceptionally trying situation so
this is pretty recognize him James
Stockdale who was as you know the vice
presidential candidate associated with
Ross Perot in 1980 but perhaps more
relevantly companion of John McCain's in
a prison in Vietnam during the Vietnam
War for about five years and Stockdale
after he was released from prison wrote
a book called testing Epictetus in the
cauldron of war and it was an
exploration of the ways in which for
himself
this epic Tatum distinction between
things that are within your control and
things that are not was something that
allowed him to survive the circumstances
in which he finds himself and so he
writes on September 9th 1965
I flew at 500 knots right into a flak
trap at treetop level in a little a for
airplane which I couldn't steer after it
was on fire it's control systems shot
out after ejection he continues I had
about 30 seconds to make my last
statement in freedom before I landed in
the main street of the little village
ahead as and so help me i whispered to
myself five years down there at least
i'm leaving the world of technology and
entering the world of
Epictetus and the book goes on to
describe the ways
in which during that half decade of
imprisonment the capacity to distinguish
between things which were in his control
that is his responses to the situations
that confronted him and things that were
not in his control that is the tortures
which were being inflicted upon him was
what allowed him to maintain a feeling
of dignity in my thoughts he says as I
ejected from that airplane was the
understanding that I would commit to
keeping separate files for those things
that are up to me and those that are not
everything in category B are external
beyond my control dooming me to fear and
anxiety if I covet them by contrast all
in category a are properly subjects for
my concern and involvement they include
my opinions my aims my aversions my
grief my joy my judgments my attitudes
about what is going on but of course as
Stockdale himself recognized changing
one's attitudes to allow this division
into the categories of things that are
in your control and things that are not
requires a recognition that we can't
merely look to our reflective self to
the answers for the answers to those
questions that because our soul has
these parts that learning to try not to
control the things in category a is not
merely a matter of rational commitment
to so doing but also a matter of the
cultivation of habits that so doing
requires being surrounded by a community
of others to whom one can turn for
support and
once those pieces are in place it's
possible truly to recognize and to act
on the insight that some things are up
to us and some things indeed are not so
thanks and I'm happy to take questions